How would you like to win your very own
Thermaltch Core P3? In partnership with
Thermaltch, I'm giving away three of
these beautiful, awesome cases. To
enter, sign up at our forum at
hardwarebox.com. Post a picture of your
current rig, your specs, and quickly
tell me what you want to do with the
CP3. Good luck and enjoy the video.
[Music]
The time has come to benchmark the new
Radian RX 470 and benchmark it with
Shell. For those of you expecting some
20 plus games tested, I've got to
apologize. You'll have to settle for a
dozen this time around. Unfortunately, I
only found out the RX 470 was incoming
late last week, and my sample arrived
less than 24 hours before the deadline.
The good news though was because I did
have almost a week's notice that the RX
470 was being released today, I was able
to do a bit of planning, which resulted
in quite a bit of pre-esting. The key
part of the plan was to change my test
system for these lower-end/midrange
graphics cards to something that would
closer reflect the setups those shopping
for a sub $200 GPU would be running.
This meant dumping the overclocked Core
i7 6700 K system for a more affordable
Core i3 rig. In the end, I went with the
Core i3 6100T, which is roughly three
times cheaper than the 6T700 K. I
deliberately opted for the low voltage
model as it comes clocked at just 3.2
GHz and will better reflect the
performance of locked processors.
Typically, graphics cards are
benchmarked using high-end rigs to avoid
system bottlenecks, and this makes a lot
of sense. That said, for this review, I
wanted to try doing things a little
different to the norm. After all, you're
going to see countless RX 470 reviews go
live alongside mine, and the vast
majority will no doubt feature a Core i7
test rig. Additionally, the response to
my video where I tested the RX 480 and
GTX 1060 on 6-year-old AMD and Intel
computers was very wellreceived. So,
with almost a week up my sleeve, I took
nine graphics cards in the sub $300
price range and tested them at 1080p and
a dozen new and relatively new AAA
titles. Now that we have the RX 470 on
hand, it'll be interesting to see how it
compares. For more information regarding
the RX 470, please check out the AMD
Radian RX 460 and RX 470 preview video I
put together last week. In that video, I
speculated the RX 470 would cost $180,
despite almost all news reports claiming
a $150 price tag. Quite a few of you
guys felt the RX 470 would come in at
$150, but frankly, I couldn't see it
happening. I'm not expecting this new
GPU to be much slower than the RX 480,
and at $150, the RX470 wouldn't just be
the buy of the year. would also have
heavily cannibalized the RX480 sales.
The $180 US MSRP means down under the
RX470 should cost around $240 based on a
rough currency conversion. That said,
the cheapest price the RX480 is being
advertised for in Australia is $360,
while you still have to pay $440 to find
one in stock. Based on that information,
I expect the cheapest RX 470 will cost
us Aussies around 320 bucks, which is
roughly what I paid a few days ago for
the R9 380X used for comparison in this
video. All graphics cards tested a
reference models, and those that aren't
have had their bias reflashed to meet
the reference clock speeds. AMD provided
the ASUS RX 470 Stricks Edition for
review, which does feature a decent
factory overclock. So, for the purposes
of this review, I've downclocked the
ASUS card to the reference clock
frequencies to keep the results fair.
For that reason, I haven't included
overclocking in this video and instead
at a later date, I'll do a full review
of the Stricks Edition and provide
factory and custom overclocking results.
Okay, so that gets the important stuff
out of the way. Let's get to the
results, shall we? We'll begin our
benchmarks with Batman Arkham Knight.
Here you can see the 470 managed a
healthy 85 FPS, meaning it was within 7%
of its bigger brother, the RX 480. This
is one of the few titles, too, where the
RX 480 was ahead of the 1060. And as a
result, the 470 was within 6% of the
Nvidia card. Compared to the 380X of the
previous generation, we're now looking
at a card that's 10 FPS faster. Again,
the 470 performed extremely well. This
time in Black Ops 3. Here, it was good
for 92 FPS, making it just 3 FPS shy of
the 480. This time, however, the 1060
was more true to its average relative
performance and was 12% faster at 105
FPS. This is the game where the 470 lay
its biggest beating on the 380X of
yesterday year, trouncing it by 23%. Our
Doom test were conducted using Vulcan.
And here, the 470s performance was
rather impressive. It was able to
eclipse the much more expensive GTX 1060
by 4 FPS, but was 15% behind the RX 480
and the 390. This time, the 380X again
trail behind, this time by 20%. Next up
was Far Cry Primal, and here the 470 was
within three frames of the 480 under
these conditions, which was obviously
pretty negligible. It was however 15%
slower than the 1060, although both
cards provided very smooth gaming
experiences. In Shadow of Mordor, the
480 was able to extend its lead again,
this time out to 14%. The 1060 was also
18 FPS ahead, meaning the 470 was 20%
slower. In Mirror's Edge Catalyst, on
the medium quality settings were able to
extract a smooth 74 FPS on the RX 470.
This was quite close to the performance
of the 480, which was only 4 FPS ahead
on 78. The 1060 led the pack again, and
this time, the 470 was 21% slower. The
stronger cards in our testing pack were
possibly reaching a CPU bottleneck here
in Overwatch on the ultra quality
setting here. The 1060, 480, and 470
were all within four frames of each
other, and the 380X was 7% behind the
470 specifically. We tested Rise of the
Tomb Raider in DirectX12 with the very
high quality settings, and the 470
managed a smooth 84 fps, which was great
to see. This was 15% faster than the
380X and 10% behind the RX 480. Star
Wars Battlefront was an interesting one.
Here, the top three cards all seem to
hit the same bottleneck at 107 FPS, and
the 470 was 18% behind on 88 FPS. The
380X, though, was even further behind at
79. In the division, the 470 was
slightly faster than the much more
power- hungry R9390 with 68 FPS. It was
12% slower than its bigger brother from
the same generation and 14% behind the
mid-range and more expensive 1060 from
the Green Team. The Witcher 3 was one of
the games where the 470 was quite close
to the 480, this time just 7% behind.
was also only 11% slower than the 1060,
which is a good showing. Compared with
some of the last generation's cards, it
smoked the 1060 by 50% and was 17%
faster than the 380X. This time, I
tested Total War Warhammer and
DirectX12, and the R9 390 was king of
the hill. The margins weren't huge,
though, and the 470 fell only 2 FPS
behind the RX 480 and 3 FPS behind the
1060. The 380 and 380X were all in the
same ballpark, too, though, with 59 and
60 FPS, respectively. The total system
power consumption on average over 20
minutes of gameplay at 1080p was a
relatively low 201 watt. This was 17
watts less than the RX 480 reference
card, which seems about spot-on based on
the performance. As mentioned, the RX
470 we're using here is of the ASUS
stricks variety, whereas the RX 480 is
only the honestly pretty poorly cooled
reference card, and the results speak
for themselves. ASUS seems to have
devised a pretty damn effective cooler.
And as you can see, after 20 minutes of
gameplay, it was still sitting at a
comparatively icy cool 59°. This is
compared to a coffee brewing 81° from
the 480 reference card and 71° from the
GTX 1060 Founders Edition. Interesting
results for sure, but I've got to say
that they're quite in line with what I
was expecting based on the
specifications we had before I finally
got the card and was able to test it.
The power consumption is low, but also
in line with the performance scene, and
the temperatures maintained by the
Stricks card are actually really
impressive. Now, let's jump into the
part of the review I personally find
most interesting and useful, the direct
card comparisons. In a direct comparison
with the RX 380, here you can see it was
on average 20% faster at 1080p. There's
quite a spread of results, though,
ranging quite steadily from 5% all the
way up to 35%. I was really interested
to see how the 380X and 470 stacked up,
as there two cards from different
generations that feature the exact same
core configuration. As you can see, the
new Polaris card is 13% faster on
average through our dozen games tested.
And again, there's quite a spread of
results. In our Total War Direct X12
test, the cards were only separated by
2%, whereas in Black Ops 3, the 470 was
able to pull away by 23%. Obviously,
this is another comparison that I, and
most likely you are, are very interested
to see. Compared directly to the RX 480
reference card, the 470 was an average
only 8% slower, as I thought it might
be. Due to our testing conditions, there
are a couple of games where a system
bottleneck was present, and this is why
Overwatch, for instance, was within 1%.
This 8% average, however, is why I knew
this card wouldn't be coming in at a
price as low as
$150. The new RX 470 put a fair beating
on the GTX 960, and at its closest, it
was still 19% ahead. On average, though,
it was a whopping 42% faster, meaning
the 470 would be a significant upgrade
for GTX 960 users. These cards are
really in totally different price
categories, but it was interesting to
see that in a number of titles, the
difference when paired with a lower-end
processor was quite small. In a third of
our games tested, the RX 470 was only 6%
slower or less. And in the case of Doom
running in Vulcan, it was actually
faster. This meant that overall, the
average was 12% slower, and the largest
margin was in Rise of the Tomb Raider,
where the 470 was 24% slower than the
1060. AMD are pitching the RX 470 is the
perfect 1080p gaming solution. And
having seen an average of 88 FPS over
our 12 games tested, I'd have to agree.
Coming into the cost per frame of just
$25, the RX 470 is now the new cost per
frame king. And at 1080p, it looks like
there's no better buy. These figures
might look slightly different with a
higherend CPU, as in a couple of games,
there was a system bottleneck present,
but these instances were kind of
insignificant because performance was
already well over 100 FPS. The 380X was
next best in terms of cost per frame,
but the new 470 still wiped the floor
with a saving of 29 cents per frame. So,
unless availability for the 470 is
shocking, you use a high refresh rate
monitor, or there's a large price
discrepancy in your region for 1080p
gaming, it seems like there'll be no
better choice than AMD's new RX 470.
What do you guys think? Let me know in
the comments. I'm your host, Matt, as
always, and I'll see you guys next time.
YouTubers like me depend on your support
to continue improving the quality and
content of our videos. To support the
channel directly, consider becoming a
patron to also get access to a heap of
cool rewards and exclusive giveaways.
Also, don't forget you can check prices
and buy the products I looked at in this
video through the Amazon links in the
video description below. Thank you
kindly for supporting me and the
Hardware Unbox channel. It means a lot
to me and I really do appreciate it. And
in return, I'll continue to work as hard
as I can to keep producing the content
you enjoy.